eu and japanese leaders have agreed to
strengthen their partnership in the wake
of russia's invasion of ukraine european
commission president usually vandalian
accompanied by european council
president shal michel held talks with
japanese prime minister fumio kishida in
tokyo the sides also agreed on a new
digital partnership which will among
other things focus on improving the
global supply of crucial semiconductors
later addressing a joint press
conference the leader spoke of stepping
up sanctions against russia and greater
cooperation
russia's invasion of ukraine shakes the
foundations of the international order
not only in europe but also in asia
and this is absolutely unacceptable
in cooperation with the g7 including the
eu
japan will implement strong sanctions
against russia and strengthened support
to ukraine
let me finish prime minister
by thanking you warmly
for the admirable solidarity that japan
showed
by diverting some of its lng supplies to
europe
it was at a crucial time for us
at the height of the european heating
season
and we will not forget this
this shows the power and the solidarity
of democracies working together and
joining me now from tokyo for more on
this is michito suruoka he's an
associate professor at care university
and specializes in international
security and european politics professor
suroqua japan and the eu have always
been close partners but what impact has
two years of covet 19 and the ukraine
war had on this partnership
okay the ukraine war
has a lot of a big big impact on the eu
japan relationship which is the scene as
a sort of catalyst for more contact and
more closer coordination between the two
because what we are seeing now is an
unprecedented level of coordination and
dialogue between the two partners mainly
on ukraine economic sanctions against
ukraine but at the same time in the g7
context as well japan and the eul
the the part of g7 process and also in
the context of g7 we have seen a huge
number of foreign ministers meetings and
summit meetings
so the level of coordination and
cooperation between japan andy both
bilaterally and also in the context of
g7 has increased quite a lot
now prime minister kishida talked of the
ukraine war shaking the foundation of
the international order not only in
europe but also in asia
what does he mean by that
yes though what prime minister shira has
been emphasizing
is the fact that the european security
and the security in the pacific
are indivisible
so there's a huge linkage between the
two and also particularly the we we we
need to prevent
uh the the the change of status quo by
force
from taking place again in asia so that
that is why we should not uh
we should not allow the war in ukraine
as a precedent for another crisis or
another invasion in the indo-pacific
region so that's what
the tokyo is very much uh focusing on
right now in the context of the linkage
between two regions
so in the context of this is tokyo
essentially talking about beijing and
the china's assertiveness in the region
yeah that's what we are very much
focusing on because because of
geographical proximity and also the
rising
tensions in south china sea and east
china sea and uh so that's what the
tokyo needs to address
so the yeah so it's i think it's just
natural for japan to look at the linkage
between the two regions and the linkage
between
russia and china and relations between
the two countries
now speaking of linkages japan like
europe has a very close trade
relationship with china
but
far difficult bilateral relations as
compared to most countries in europe uh
i wonder therefore where does the eu fit
into japan's strategy
on that front
in dealing with china you mean
correct yes
the
yes in terms of dealing with china
the
china is a big neighbor and china is
really one of the most important trading
partners for japan so the
business community in japan
is very much interested in doing
continuing business with china of course
and that's also very much in japan's
national interest
and but at the same time we have various
a wide range of concerns about china
and
in terms of dealing with
various economic problems then the
japan needs to get other like-minded
countries on board so we very much
cooperate with the united states of
course but at the same time the eu is a
like-minded partner sharing values and
sharing various concerns about china as
well so that is why there is a growing
interest in japan in working more
closely with the eu
so the in terms of ensuring the market
access for example
or or the treatment of private companies
investors in china
and the the intellectual property rights
and the diseases as well
so the and also the we are increasingly
uh interested in cooperating with
americans and european partners in terms
of dealing with human rights issues and
hong kong issues as well
so the
in the context of the war in ukraine
those
china related issues are now
seen as more invisible but but the
challenges are there and uh perhaps the
challenges are increasing so the i think
the fact that eu leaders
visited japan
amid the war in ukraine i think it's a
great demonstration that the europeans
are
still very much engaged in the
indo-pacific region
and uh certainly not forgetting the
importance of this region so just that
that i think was a great
powerful message so this week actually
we also saw a a visit by finnish prime
minister right so the
so this is sort of a return of in-person
diplomacy
i i think it
is great after after two two years of
pandemic right
a pleasure talking to you thank you for
bringing that perspective to us
professor michito suruoka from ko
university thank you sir
you